kommt die Kindergrundsicherung
ursprünglich das ampelrezept gegen
Kinderarmut beim Amtsantritt ein
vollmundiges Versprechen der
Familienministerin jetzt werden wir die
Kinder Grundsicherung endlich so
gestalten dass sie wirksam vor Armut
schützt und ankommt einen
Paradigmenwechsel will sie aber nicht
zum Nulltarif 12 Milliarden fordert die
Ministerin die jedoch der Finanzminister
nicht locker machen will und zwar mit
Rückendeckung des Kanzlers Paus
Eckpunkte sehen vor mehr Geld ins System
zu punkten für alle Kinder ein
garantiebetrag Plus
einkommensabhängig ein Zusatzbetrag geht
nicht sagt der Koalitionspartner es sei
bereits Milliarden geflossen wenn wir
eine kleine Glanz ziehen dann stellen
wir fest dass der Kinderzuschlag erhöht
wurde dass das Kindergeld erhöht wurde
wenn man dann strich runterzieht komme
ich ungefähr bei 7 Milliarden Euro aus
das ist schon Geld was dieser Pause
jetzt schon zur Verfügung steht
angesichts der Kassenlage hat sich die
Ministerin einen Kniff überlegt sie
schlägt vor den Steuerfreibetrag für
Kinder von besser verdienenden an
ärmere umzuverteilen doch auch die Idee
stößt auf Widerstand auch aus der
Zivilgesellschaft es ist kein sinnvoller
Vorschlag weil auch bei wenn man beim
Kinderfreibetrag kürzen würde
verfassungswidrig wäre es zum einen und
außerdem würde man Mittelstandsfamilien
ärmere Familien finanzieren lassen der
Kampf gegen die Kinderarmut ein
Dauerthema in der Politik
milliardenprogramme und trotzdem immer
noch schätzungsweise jedes fünfte Kind
in Deutschland armutsgefährdet unser
Ziel ist nachhaltig Kinderarmut senken
sein ganz konkreter Schritt zur
Bekämpfung der Kinderarmut der seit
vielen Jahren gefordert wird Kinderarmut
in einem reichen Land wie Deutschland
ist eine Schande erst in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode wurde der
Kinderzuschlag für Beruf Politiker mit
niedrigen Einkommen reformiert zu
kompliziert zu bürokratisch hieß es
lediglich 30% der Berechtigten nehmen
ihn überhaupt in Anspruch drei Jahre
später habe sich laut Ampel daran nichts
verändert und wir wissen zum Beispiel
von dem Kinderzuschlag dass der nur zu
knapp 30 Prozent genutzt wird diese Zahl
ist eine alte Zahl aus den Jahren
2018/2019 danach gab es keine
Neubewertung wir kennen die absoluten
Zahlen aber keine Prozentzahl und die
Ministerin hat sie in den Raum gestellt
diese absoluten Zahlen beim
Kinderzuschlag sind ganz erheblich
gestiegen von
250.000 auf 800.000 und trotzdem bleibt
die Ministerin bei der alten Prämisse
den 30 %. wir liegen keine aktuellen
Zahlen vor ich muss mich auf das Stützen
was von dem Forschungsinstitut berechnet
worden ist das ist ein renommiertes
Institut und danach sehen die Zahlen so
aus aber richtig ist ist das in
Krisenzeiten die Armut auch noch mal
zunimmt ist jetzt auch keine völlige
Überraschung der Milliarden Poker
zugunsten der schwächsten zwischen
Wunsch und Wirklichkeit ohne Einigung in
Sicht die Kinder Grundsicherung erinnert
mich so ein bisschen anders Bürgergeld
beim Bürgergeld ist auch ein schöneres
Etikett gefunden worden als Hartz IV
oder Arbeitslosengeld 2 und bei der
Kindergrundsicherung scheint es auch so
zu sein dass ein neues Etikett gefunden
wird keine zusätzlichen Milliarden
betont der Finanzminister erst heute
wieder keine Umverteilung das
Prestigeprojekt der Ampel wird zerrieben
trotz Geld Sorgen vieler Familien